It's show time.
Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show, I'm your
host Paul and unfortunately saul goodman things
must come to an end as not only is Better
Call Saul now over but the crap puns on the
show are too.
Throughout this video we're gonna be breaking
it all down, going through what happens and
also the easter eggs in it.
Also if you wanna support the show we've just
launched a Better Call Paul T-shirt over at
our shop Zero edition which will be linked
below.
If you need a spoiler then you chumps know
who to call and I hope you head over there
to pick up this limited run t-shirt, it really
helps us out, means I can buy myself a golden
toilet and it helps videos like this get made.
Now last week saw Marion discovering the truth
about Gene through finding Saul's old commercials.
Even though she ended up calling the police
she still probably liked and subscribed and
this led to Jimmy going on the run once more.
The preview had us focusing on his ditched
car from earlier in the series and over the
top of this we could hear him desperately
trying to get himself a new identity.
-
Now they sort of spliced two scenes together
for that with the hoover call almost being
a sort of What If that we never actually see
out.
However the car is there which is very important
to how we open things up.
Though Gene gets caught a lot faster than
we thought, this idea of identity is very
important to bear in mind as we finally see
Jimmy rest on one and for once he does the
right thing.
The colour also gave a clue to what time period
we'd be in and this is actually where we begin
everything.
Now we open with a flashback to Season Bagman
and catch Mike and Jimmy in the desert.
This was one of the standout episodes in the
series and this entry very much feels like
a time machine trip with us getting several
cameos such as Mike, Marie, Walt, Bill Oakley,
Chuck and a couple of big characters.
Time machines are a major talking point of
the entry and we see Jimmy talking about them
with Mike and Walt before he picks up the
book by HG Wells when he's with Chuck.
This opening is a great way to start us off
and after finding a water tank both Jimmy
and Mike discuss regrets, the future and it's
basically just an introspective look at the
characters.
I love how Jimmys water has a suspiciously
yellow liquid in it and it shows how desperate
that he is.
These time machine conversations that appear
throughout all take place at pivotal points
in his life and they're very much intersections
in which we see how his regrets change.
Jimmy says that they could take the money
and he would use six million of it to build
a time machine.
Mike says that he'd go back to March 17th
1984 aka the day he took his first bribe.
This had a massive impact on the character
as not only did it lead him down the road
to becoming a criminal but it also led to
the death of his son Matt.
He says he'd also go forward to see how people
were doing, clearly referring to his family
and those he cares about.
Jimmy on the other hand is all about the dough
and he'd rather go back in time and invest
the other million into Warren Buffetts Berkshire
Hathaway.
It's very much just the case of using a time
machine to go back and win the lottery because
all that Jimmy cares about is money.
Clearly he'd have a lot of things he'd change
but at this point he's so materialistic that
he believes wealth is the key to happiness.
From here we cut to the titles.
-
In this we can catch the isotopes air freshner
from Jeffs cab and this was also something
that very much led to Genes downfall.
Had he not got in that cab he probably would've
been stuck as the manager of Cinnabon but
it gave him an avenue where he went back to
old habits.
I also view this as being the moment that
Jimmy was caught as it set up the dominoes
that led to everything falling apart.
We then jump immediately to the other side
of last week with us even hearing the door
close behind him as he bolts out of Marions.
She describes his car and also the direction
hes going in.
He grabs everything he can from his home and
I love how he has a stack of flip phones in
his cupboard.
Not only is this a cool nod to him selling
phones but it also shows how prepared that
he is incase it all goes t*ts up.
Jimmy ends up trying to call out to my man
the hoover guy but unfortunately he messes
up and is caught.
Now often when you hear of criminal masterminds
being caught you'll hear of how they're found
in some of the worst circumstances trying
to evade the law.
This is very much the case with Jimmy who
due to his confession will be labelled as
having one of the biggest drug empires in
America.
He's found in a dumpster after failing to
escape the law and him stoopings to these
depths shows how far he's fallen from his
mansions and sexy suits.
Now in some of the best foreshadowing I've
ever seen, episode 1 in this season actually
started off with a shot of his cardboard cut
out being put into a dumpster.
It really shows the attention to detail that
the series carries and how it sets up things
far in advance.
I love this moment and it gives me chills
going back to watch this to see how it hinted
at whats to come.
-
This is echoed in the commercial that we see
the police watching.
We can hear his over the top bravado narration
about how he can get anyone out of jail whilst
we see him looking at what would normally
be a one way ticket.
He gets his one phone call and he uses it
to contact Cinnabon to tell them they'll need
a new manager.
Got lots of flashes here of Gus calling up
to make sure los pollos hermanos had a manager
in place after he was shot and it's nice that
they show the similarities in the characters
when they're at their lowest points.
Now Jimmy demands another phonecall after
seeing a carving about a lawyer doing...doing
what and he reaches out to Bill Oakley.
Better Call Bill spin off coming soon baby.
As we saw earlier in the season he's now switched
sides to become a defense attorney.
He ends up taking Jimmys case and I love how
Saul sells him on how big it'll be for him.
-
Now at this point we get a cameo by Marie
and the authorities basically want to throw
the book at him.
Initially he's facing life plus 190 years
but Saul comes out on top.
He's initially offered a deal of 30 years
but he asks for Marie to come in after referring
to her as Schraeders Widow.
Really tragic way to see her labelled like
this and watching her talk about Hank and
Steve Gomez is really heartbreaking to watch.
Reminds you of how much they really were the
good guys and how Hank would always come in
with a smile and a joke even in the darkest
times.
Miss you man...
-
She says that he did it all for money, further
linking back to the first time machine conversation.
It's so tragic but Saul twists things so that
he's seen as a victim just like her.
It's incredible watching him go to work and
he mentions the name Mayhew which was the
surname of Badger from Breaking Bad.
Saul talks about being taken into the desert
and he basically spins it to say that he feared
for his life the entire time.
Walt of course led to the deaths of several
people which Saul has knowledge of.
He touches upon big moments from Breaking
Bad such as the ten men being murdered in
prison at the same time and he also brings
up Dan from the series.
The prosecutor asks if he thinks the Jury
are gonna buy it but he smiles and says.
-
Now it turns out that the prosecutor has never
lost a case before and this has given him
not only an ego but also the fear that the
first L is right around the corner.
He's well aware that there's potential that
Jimmy can drop this sob story in the court
and win one of them round.
Though Marie doesnt want them to negotiate
he ends up working with Jimmy and they cut
his sentence down to seven years.
Jimmy is so in control of the entire thing
he even picks not only his prison but also
the wing that he'll be on.
He chooses the only federal institution with
a golf programme and brings up Bernie Madoff.
Incase you don't know, Bernie was the ex-chairman
of the Nasdaq stock exchange and he also ran
the biggest ponzi scheme in history, totalling
in at a whopping 64 billion.
Jimmy will do anything to avoid Gen pop and
this is important to bear in mind to show
what hes sacrificing in the end.
He gets too arrogant though and in order for
more stuff like ice cream he says he'll offer
up info on Howard's death.
However they reveal that Kim already gave
everything up which sweeps Jimmy off his feet.
Cut to the Walt and Jimmy in the moment before
they were both shipped off to their new lives.
In the case of both they ended up coming back
and we also get a time machine conversation
here.
Walt at one point looks at his watch which
was gifted to him as a present by Jesse in
Breaking Bad.
This is a TAG Heuer Monaco that was given
to the Monaco Grand Prix winner in 1969.
It was also worn by Steve McQueens character
in the 1971 film Le Mans.
The one Walt has is a 2004 reissue and he
showed it to Skylar saying that a man who
tried to kill him once ended up giving him
it as a present, this showed that she would
forgive him one day too.
Here its used in a number of ways to show
how long theyve been waiting, to tie in with
the time machine and its got some really nice
symbolism to it.
Jimmy wants to run the thought experiment
again but Walt wants to cut the BS and he
disregards it as being scientifically impossible.
He realises that Saul just wants to talk about
regrets and he brings up Gray Matter.
Walt blames his old pals for kicking him out
the company because of how rich he'd end up
becoming.
This mindstate very much explains why he ends
up tormenting them in the finale of Breaking
Bad as he sees them as artfully removing him.
Saul leaps to his feet but hes quickly shut
down.
Jimmy brings up how he slipped once and hurt
himself and you could say he was slipping
jimmy.
-
Come on that was good, anyway this leads Walt
to say.
-
Cut to Jimmy on the plane still using his
mouth to get what he wants and he finds out
about what Kim gave up.
He also discovers that Cheryl got the info
too so she can now open up a civil suit.
This gets Jimmys brain spinning and he says
that he's got more to trade on Kim.
Cut to her back at the lunch table with her
coworkers and it's clear that she's just not
happy.
She ends up walking out of her job and we
follow her as she volunteers at pro-bono law
firm.
Though its not much it shows that shes slowly
back on the road to becoming her old self
again but this is crushed when Suzanne calls
her to tell she may be implicated in the new
proceedings.
Really devastating watching her learn and
I was kinda worried that Kims life could end
up being destroyed too.
She very much had her redemption arc last
week and handed over everything on Howard
so seeing things could get worse is realy
devastating.
We see Saul rock up in the shiniest suit he
could find looking like his old sleazeball
self.
However the guilt starts to wash over him
as he sees Kim and Marie and this very much
plays into his next move.
He goes under the name Saul Goodman and we
watch as he goes off into his sob story after
the judge asks why he's getting off so lightly.
This is verbatim to how he said it in the
prosecution office and it's clearly all an
act.
However, he quickly shifts gears and he starts
lying to the court in order to take the fall.
He says he was the one who helped build up
Walt's drug empire.
He says he lied about Kims involvement because
he wanted her to come to the court and this
is very much an apology to her.
We saw how he tried to save her with Lalo
and this is very much the same thing here
with him saving the woman he loved.
Trying not to cry watching my dude doing the
right thing and he does it all to make sure
that Kim is ok.
He says that without him that Walt wouldve
been dead or in prison without him and he
also takes the fall for Hank and Gomez in
some way.
Next he brings up Howard and his voice cracks
as he credits Kim for starting over again
and actually doing the right thing in handing
herself in.
We get some great iconography here with a
focus on the exit sign overhead and he goes
off to talk about Chuck and how he hurt him.
He destroyed the law for Chuck which led to
him ending his own life and he finally takes
responsibility for it.
The scene then gives us a Chuck flashback
to Jimmy helping him out whilst he still had
his electricity phobia.
Chuck tells him that if he doesnt like where
he's heading that there's no shame in going
back and changing things.
Chuck picks up his copy of the time machine
and he then goes to bed.
Now this book also popped up in Episode 1
of this season and we could see it as the
mansion got raided.
It's such another bit of amazing foreshadowing
to whats to come and Jimmy very much used
his confession as a way to go back and change
things.
Though not literally a time machine it corrected
some of his regrets and we watch as hes taken
to a terrible prison.
One of the other prisoners recognises that
he's Saul Goodman and though he corrects this
to Jimmy, the legend lives on.
The entire bus starts a chant that brings
a sad smile to Jimmys face and inside the
prison we cut to him flipping dough.
The scene here very much resembles the way
that the stuff in Cinnabon was shot showing
how nomatter what path he took he still would've
ended up doing this.
Really poetic and we watch as he's called
out to meet Kim.
This scene mirrors how they'd meet in the
carpark and share cigarettes and we even get
some similar iconography to that.
This scene genuinely gave me goosebumps throughout
with it's long pauses and you can feel how
much they really care about each other but
how they know they'll never get their happy
ending.
The flame lights up in another burst of colour
showing how much this old flame brings the
colour into his life.
We learn Jimmy is now doing 86 years but with
good behaviour who knows.
It's bitter sweet as he's still gonna spend
the rest of his life in jail and he knows
it.
However he sees her on the outside going off
to now live her life free of the torment she
couldve faced.
Jimmy shoots his gun fingers at her as she
departs and I'm not crying...you're crying.
Anyone whos had a breakup where you just want
the other person to be happy can relate a
lot to the sorrow displayed here and that
closes out Better Call Saul in what was a
fitting but also devastating end to the show.
I think we all knew that Jimmy would get his
comeuppance but we can take some solace in
knowing that at least Kim will be ok.
Now as for my thoughts on the series I think
that Better Call Saul always had a difficult
job because it was obviously a prequel/sequel
to one of the best TV shows of all time.
However, they managed to do what so many others
fail to and at points I actually think this
was better than Breaking Bad.
The early seasons of that are good but I think
it takes a couple of them before we really
get into what made the show must watch whereas
here it hit the ground running for me early
on and maintained a consistent level throughout.
The final season has been no different and
it's arguably had the most impactful moments
from the entire season playing out almost
back to back at points.
There was of course Nachos death, Howards,
Lalos, the break up of Kim and Jimmy, Gene
going back to his old ways and several big
moments that made this at an almost masterpiece
in storytelling at points.
I've often said that prequels are difficult
to do because we already know where the story
eventually ends up.
However whereas most fail to utilise this,
Better Call Saul does because we worry that
our favourite characters might die and that
will explain why they're not in Breaking Bad.
On top of this there's also so many great
performances and memorable characters.
You can pretty much pick out any member of
the cast and chances are they're gonna have
hit a home run.
The actors behind this show really sold everything
and there were so many moments where so little
was spoken but it spoke so much to what the
characters were going through.
That's why I really loved it and why I think
the series has been one i'll probably go back
and rewatch because of the quality it delivered.
I hope you enjoyed our breakdowns on the second
half too and hopefully I'll see you around
on the channel for our coverage of other shows
We’re running a competition right now and
giving away 3 copies of Top Gun Maverick On
The 15th Of September.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
We pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me @heavySpoilers
if that’s you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing so it’s definitely
worth checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace